difficile de reconnaître la marque ou le
type de véhicule les dégâts sont
impressionnants
au total onze véhicules ont été détruits
cet incendie est intervenue dans la nuit
peu avant 4 heures bon il ya la société
en face qui est en train de tramer 110
soudain et violent
s'il est travaillé dans une entreprise
voisine c'est lui qui a donné l'alerté
il y avait vraiment un très très très
gros incendie c'était impressionnant ça
fait peur du coup on a appelé les
pompiers c'était impressionnant du fait
qu'il ya beaucoup de véhicules dedans
donc ça a explosé
on entendait des pneus enfin pas mal de
choses beaucoup d'explosions donc du
coup on était un petit peu inquiet quoi
les responsables de cette entreprise
adaptée pour travailleurs handicapés la
firme
si les dégâts sont considérables il n'y
aura pas de chômage technique
contacté par téléphone le parquet
confirme l'origine volontaire du
sinistre
l' enquête a été confiée à la sûreté
départementale de la police
fait troublant quatre autres départs de
feu ont été enregistrés cette nuit dans
dijon